[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه الان تقى واحداث وتتفاعل اخرى هذه
الصور من العاصمه الاكرانيه كيف
شهدت احتفالات اليوم بعد اعلان استعاده
خيلسون اثرا انسحاب القوات الروسيه
هذه الصور من العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن
حيث مازالت بعض الولايات الامريكيه بصدد
فرز الاصوات في انتخابات التجديد النصفي
للكونغرس
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
القوات الروسيه تعلن اكتمال انسحابها من
غيرسون الى الضفه الشرقيه لنهر دينيبر
وتقول انها نقلت اكثر من 30,000 جندي
الرئيس الاوكراني يؤكد دخول القوات الخاصه
وسط المدينه ويصف الحدث بالتاريخ والكريم
للي يقول ان الموقفه من وضع خرسانه جزء من
روسيا لم يتغير
قبيله عقوبات اوروبيه مرتقبه على ايران
فرنسا وبريطانيا توديناني دعم طهران لحرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا وما وصفته بانشطه
طهران المزعزي على الاستقرار بالشرق
الاوسط البانتجون يتخوف من هجمات ايرانيه
بالمنطقه وقائد الحرس الثوري يقول ان
العدو يوجه رسائله يطالب فيها بعدم فني اي
هجوم
على موعد مع اكثر الحكومات يمنيه الرئيس
الاسرائيلي يعتزم تكليف نتنياهو بتشكيل
الحكومه بعد تزكيه 64 عضوا في الكنيسه
وشخصيات تونسيه
تبدي تخوفها من الحكومه المدمع تشكيلها
على مستقبل اسرائيل
تونس وازمات الاقتصاد المتفمه اتحاد الشغل
يحذر الحكومه من الاستمرار في سياسات تنذر
بانفجارات اجتماعيه وينتقد غياب الاراده
لحل الازمه والتفرد بالقرار
والقوى السياسيه بينها احزاب مؤيده للرئيس
السيد يحمل الحكومه المسؤوليه والرئيس
التونسيه يقول ان مسار الخامس والعشرين من
يوليو كان ضروريا لانقاذ الدوله ويؤكد ان
الكلمه النهائيه ستكون للشعب
في لقاءنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه نقشنا الفوضى السائده حاليا في
منصه التويتر حيث جرت عده استقالات
لمديرين ومسؤولين في امن المعلومات
والخصوصيه ويقول مالك المنصه الى الماس
انه لا يستبعد الافلاس في حال عدم تحسين
الايرادات خلال الفتره المقبله اضطرابات
تاتي وسط قرار من علامات تجاريه مشهوره
ايقافه اعلنتها على المنصه تخوفا من تخفيف
ماسك لقواعد الاشراف على المحتوى
رايكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم كيف ستنعكس
الاستقالات والتطورات الجاريه حاليا على
مستقبل تويتر 17 بالمئه قالوا انها ستؤدي
الى تعريض الشركه للافلاس بينما 30 بالمئه
او انها ستسبب انهيارا في المنصه وتراجع
لها
53% ان هذه التطورات ستدفع نحو تعديلات في
الاداره والسياسه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه
الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا
مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايمن
المفوضيه الاوروبيه تعلن مجموعه اليورو
على موعد مع الكماش
[موسيقى]
انا الرئيس
استعاده مدينه كرسون وصفا هذا اليوم
بالتاريخيه ومؤكد ان الوحدات الخاصه في
الجيش الاوكرانيه موجوده
الى الاستسلام
هذا وقد قال الكريم ان الموقف من وضع
خرسون كجزء من روسيا لم يتغير
الاعلام الاوكرانيه ترفع من جديد فوق ارض
مدينه خرسون جنوب شرقي البلاد
فالمقاطعه التي دخلها الجيش الروسي بدايه
مارس الماضي وضمتها موسكو بشكل رسميا
الاراضيها قبل نحو شهر ونصف اصبح مركزها
في الضفه الغربيه لنهر دنيرو تحت السيطره
الكامله للجيش الاوكراني ورغم اعلان وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه اكتمال نقل قواتها الى
الضفه الشرقيه للنهار دون ان تتكبد اي
خسائر فان الكرملين صار على التاكيد انه
لم يطرق اي تغيير على موقف موسكو باعتبار
مقاطعه خرسون جزءا من الاراضي الروسيه ما
اثار مزيدا من التساؤلات بشان ملابسات
الانسحاب الروسي من هناك وما الذي دفع
موسكو لتتحمل مخاطر نقل اكثر من 30,000
جندي ونحو خمسه الاف من الوحدات والمعدات
العسكريه وسط المعارك الى الضفه الاخرى من
النهر اذا كانت لا تزال كبير وخرصون
مقاطعه روسيه على ان اللافته ايضا هو ذلك
التزامن بين استكمال الانسحاب الروسي
وحصول انهيارات في جسر انتنوفو كخوفكا على
نهر دني برو وهم الجسران الوحيدان اللذان
يربطان بين ضفتين النهر ويصلان جانبي
خرسان ببعضهما لكل طرف روايته بشان اسباب
الانهيارات الجيش الروسي يقول انها حصلت
اثناء تبادل للقصف مع الجيش الاوكراني
خلال الانسحاب وكيف تقول ان الروس تعمد
استهداف الجسرين واين تكون الروايه الادب
فان الثابته هنا ان ذلك التدمير سيجعل من
امكانيه عوده الجيش الروسي بعتاده الثقيل
الى خرسان امرا صعبا كما سيعقل الجيش
الاوكراني عن مواصله تقدمه نحو باقي مناطق
المقاطعه الجنوبيه
المتاخمه لشبه جزيره القرم ما يجعل
استهداف القوات الروسيه القرم من البر
امرا صعب المنال بالعتاد المتوفر
الجنرال المتقاعدين بوشنكي رئيس قسم
المعاهدات الدوليه السابق في وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اهلا وسهلا بك هل نحن امام
انتكاسه عسكريه كبيره للقوات الروسيه في
اوكرانيا
لكنه مبرر قرار مبرر لسببين اولهما ان
طرق التجهيزات
حول فوقه
الجسر قد تم تدميره بشكل
مستمر لم يكن من السهل الحصول على
التجهيزات القوات الروسيه ولي سكان
تحت هذه الظروف الصعبه السبب الثاني هو
اعتقد انه سبب الرئيسي
بتدميره همم ثدي خرسان والذي قام
الاوكرانيين بقصفه بشكل مستمر من اجل
محاوله تدميره وتخريبه في هذه الحاله ما
تم تدمير السلف ان مدينه خيرسون
واربعون قاريه محيطه بها همم تغرق بالكامل
لذلك اعتقد الان
ان الدفاع على الضفه اليسرى للظهر قويه
للغايه وانا توقعوا انه خلال فصل
الشتاء سنعود الى مدينه خرسانه
اصعب من حيث تحرك القوات
الفراشه
الروسيه
كما تعرف فان في كل الحروب كل الانتصارات
الروسيه تحققت خلال فصل الشتاء نحن
المعتدون على القتال في ظروف الشتاء لذلك
اعتقد ان فصل الشتاء هو الوقت المناسب لنا
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه قالت ان
الرئيس بوتن ابعد عن هذا الخبر لم يكون في
الصوره ليس هو من اعلنه ولم يتحدث فيه
وكان هناك رغبه في ابعاد بوتن عن مشهد
هزيمه هكذا قالت الجريده ما ما رايك
ليس هنالك اي شيء في روسيا يحدث بدون
معرفه
ورخصه الرئيس والقائد العام للقوات
المسلحه الروسيه بالتالي هذا الامر هذا
القرار من قرار من وزاره الدفاع لكنه انني
متاكد انه كان اتى بموافقه الرئيس شكرا
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بك همم اعتبر هذا اليوم تاريخي
لماذا
مساء الخير
مدينه اوكرانيه مهمه خيرسون هي
المركز الاقليميه الوحيد الذي
تمكن الروس المعتدين من السيطره عليه بشكل
مؤقت الان ونحن بدخولنا الى خرسانه نحن
نثبت للعالم مره اخرى باننا هزمنا عروس
فيكي يا ابو شرنيف وفي خاركيف الان نحن
ندفعهم خارج خرسون بالتالي هذه تاتي اهميه
هذا اليوم ايضا هنالك رساله ان شعب خرسان
هم كانوا ينتظرون هذا اليوم لمده طويله هم
لم يرحبوا بالمعتدين الرؤوس كانوا يحتجون
ضد المعتدين الرؤوس منذ اليوم الاول منذ
اليوم الاول الاحتلال واليوم اخيرا هم
رحبوا بالقوات الاوكرانيه في مدينت
والحياه ستبدا بالعوده الى طبيعتها هناك
ضيفنا الروسي قبل قليل اشار الى ان خروج
القوات الروسيه يعود الى موضوع الامداد
وموضوع الخوف على
السد وبالتالي العوده ستكون في الشتاء هل
تتوقعون عوده روسيه الى نفس المنطقه
حسب خطاتهم وهذا امر لا يتعلق بواقع ارض
المعركه لكنه كذلك في خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه تمكن الجيش الروسي من تدمير سلاسل
الامدادات وخطط وخطوط الامتدادات للجيش
الروسي الجيش الاوكراني وباقتاله القويه
اثبت ان الجيش الروسي لم يتمكن لا يتمكن
من البقاء في خرسان بالتالي هم انسحبوا
اوليسكرانين يحاولون ان يفجروا الساده انا
امل ان هؤلاء الروس المعتدين الارهابيين
لا يقومون بعمل غبي لانهم قاموا بعمليه
استفزازيه في الماضي وبالتاكيد فان وزير
الدفاع قال سابقا ان ذا ما كان الروس
بالتحلب بالغابات الكافي لتفجيري سدي
خرسان وهمم لم يقوم بعمل جيد لانه لما
نظرت الى الخريطه فان جيء الجزء الايمن من
النهر مستواه عالي وسيط في حيث يتمركز
القوات الروسيه لكن كم اريد ان اؤكد ان
القوات الروسيه لم تكن لديها خطا لتفجيريا
الساده نحن نحارب ونناظر من اجل ارضنا ولا
نقوم بتدمير ارضنا وماذا عن الجرين من
الذي قام
بالاضرار بهما بهذا الشكل
برنامج
الذي رايناه اليوم كان حسب فهميت قام حدث
بسبب انسحاب القوات الروسيه لانها كانت
تشعر بالخوف من الناس
وسنقوم بذلك عاجلا ام اجلا هذا فقط
لمحاولتي فصل الجزء الاخر من النهار هم
قاموا بتدمير هذه الجسور لكن الجيش
الاوكراني كان يستهدف هذه الصور في الماضي
ليس هذه الجذور تحديدا لكن توجب علينا ان
نعيق طرق امداداتهم وتجهيزاتهم ونجعل من
المستحيل على المعتدين ان يظلوا فيه خير
قبل ان نضر بهذه الجسور
لكن الضرر كان جزئيا لكن الضرر الذي احدثه
كان ضرر ضررا
متوحشيا ولا يمكن المقارنه بين الاثنين
[موسيقى]
والبريطاني على دعم اوكرانيا السياسيه
وعسكريا واقتصاديا وشدد الوزيران في بيان
المشترك صدر في باريس على الحاجه للحد من
الارتفاع اسعار الطاقه في اطار مجموعه
السبعه وضماني امن الامدادات
البيان نبدا بما سماه دعم طهران للحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا خصوصا الطائرات
الايرانيه بدون طيار كما ندد بما وصفه
انشطه ايران المزعجعه للاستقرار في
المنطقه مؤكدا ضمانه منعها من حيازه اسلحه
نوويه
اما في وسط
فنقل موقع بوليتكو عن مسؤول في البنتاجون
القول ان ايران تخطط لسنه هجوما على
السعوديه لاستهداف البنيه التحتيه للطاقه
في المملكه على الارجح واضاف المسؤول
الامريكي ان واشنطن والرياضه وراقبان كذلك
تهديدا ايرا متزايدا للعراق على حد تعبيره
واشار الى ان الهدف من تحليق القادم
الامريكيتين في الشرق الاوسط يوم امس هو
توجيه ما سماه رساله قوه لايران واعرب
المسؤول في البنتاجون عن قلق بلاده من
تحركات ايران في المنطقه بما في ذلك نقل
طائرات مسيره الى روسيا
في المقابل قال وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه
حسين امين عبد الاهيان في اتصال هاتفي مع
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيرش قال ان الحوار والتعاونات التقليدي
بين طهران والوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
يمضي في مسار مناسب وفق تعبيره وجدد عبد
الحيان نفي بلاده بشده ارسال مسيرات
لروسيا بهدف استخدامها في الحرب على
اوكرانيا وانتقد عبد الاهيان موقفه بعض
الدول الغربيه تجاه الاحتجاجات في ايران
واصفا اياها بغير البناء معتبرا انها شجعت
على العنف في بلاده حسب تعبيرها
وقال قائد القوات الجويه في الحرس الثوري
الايرانيه اللواء امير علي حاجي زاده ان
الحرس اجر اختبار على صاروخ بالستي تفوق
سرعته سرعه الصوت واضاف حاج زاد في تصريح
لوكاله انباء تسليم انه ستتم ازاحه الستار
عن الصاروخ قريبا وفي الوقت المناسب واشار
الى ان هذا الصاروخ سيستهدفه منظومات
العدو المتطوره المضاده للسواريخ وبانه
تطويره يعد قفزه كبيره في مجال الصواريخ
حسب تعبيره
تنضم الينا من الدوحه فاطمه الصمادي
الباحثه الاولى في مركز الجزيره للدراسات
والخبيره في الشان الايرانيه اهلا وسهلا
بيك دكتور اسمادي ماذا يمكن ان نفهم من
هذا التصعيد الجديد في اللهجه بين بعض
الدول الغربيه وايران
هذه اشاره الى اللجوء الى مجلس الامن
وتفعيل البند السابع ضد ايران مما يعني ان
الدول الغربيه خاصه المانيا فرنسا
بريطانيا تسعى لاصدار قرار امم ضد ايران
مماحد المزيد من همم العقوبات ضد ايران
ايضا التركيز على موضوع المسيارات
الايرانيه هذا ايضا له همم ابعاد كثيره
لكن اهمها مسالتين انه اذا اذا صحت هذه
المساله وكانت ايران تزود روسيا
بسيارات فهذا يعني اعتبار ايران جزءا من
الحرب الدائره في همم اوكرانيا وبالتالي
ايضا التمهيد
لاجراءات ضد ايران قد تتخذ الابعاد اكثر
من البعد العقوبات اقتصاديه واذا لم يصح
ذلك ايضا فهذه محاوله لصناعه حاله تتخذ
فيها مساله المسيارات ذريعه ايضا لاجراءات
همم ضد همم ضد ايران المساله المهمه
الاخرى هي ما اشرت اليه بشان موضوع
الصواريخ وكما تعرف فان موضوع الملف
الصاروخي الايراني هو جزء او موضوع خلافه
شديد بين ايران والدول الغربيه على وجه
التحديد وحديث بروسي في الامس انه لا يمكن
ال- ال- الفصل بين مساله تطوير الملف
الصاروخ الايراني والمساله النوويه وان
ذلك سيكون له تاثير واذا ربطنا ذلك
بالتوتر الحادث بين ايران ولو وكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه فهذا هي كلها
مؤشرات تقول ان هناك نوع من التوجه
للتصعيد المتعدد الاوجه التطيره هل هذه
المؤشرات المختلفه هل هذه المؤثرات
المختلفه التي اعددتيها تعتبر نوع من
التمهيد
للقول في النهايه بان الاتفاق مجددا مع
طهران حول ملفها النووي باتم بعيدا اكثر
من السابق
الان كل هذه المؤشرات تقول بان المفاوضات
همم دخلت مرحله صعبه جدا همم بمعنى ان
المقترح الاوربي الاخير الذي قدم لايران
ايران رفضته ووجدت انه همم يعني غير مجدي
بالنسبه لمطالباتها وانها ان تبقى بدون
احياء الاتفاق النووي افضل لها من العوده
بهذه الصوره التي اقترحتها الدول الغربيه
همم على همم ايران التعثر
المفاوضات لا يعني انها همم ان هذا الملف
قد اغلق همم بالرمه مشهد جوله جديده من ال
همم من التفاوض خاصه وان ايران قد قدمت
دعوه للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ان ان
تزور ايران وهذا همم يسبق اجتماع المقرر
لحكام الوكاله او الذي ايضا من المتوقع ان
يصدر همم قرارا ااه يحث ايران او يطالب
بالزامها بالتعاون مع الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه فيما يتعلق بالمواقع
الثلاثه التي سبق للوكاله وان طرحت اسئله
وشككت بالمعلومات التي قدمتها ايران
بشانها
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الاسرائيليه
مع قاده الاحزاب الفائزه في الانتخابات
الاخيره حيث 64 نائبا في الكنيست بتزكيه
زعيم اللقود المخدرات بنيامين نتنياهو
لتشكيل الحكومه الجديده وسيحضر نتنياهو
الاحد الى الرئاسه لتسلم كتاب تكليفه
رسميا من الرئيس وستكون هذه الحكومه وفقه
الكاهنات الاكثر تصرفا في تاريخ اسرائيل
نظرا للتحالفات المرتقبه مع الاحزاب
الدينيه الدين المتشدده والجدل الاكبر هو
احتمال دم الحكومه الجديده لتمار بن غفير
الذي كان عضوا سابقا في حركته داخل
الارهابيه
بنيامين نتنياهو يعود على وشك التحالف مع
اليمين المتطرف لتشكيل حكومه ستكون الاكثر
تشددا وعنصريه في تاريخ اسرائيل الاحد هو
موعد تكلفه رسميا من قبل الرئيس يسحق
هارتسون زعيم
64 نائبا في الكنيست لقياده الحكومه
المقبله يمثلها هؤلاء الكود وتحالف
الصهيونيه الدينيه
تمثلان التيار الديني الحديدي
28 يوما لعرض حكومته امام الهيئه العامه
للكنيسه
والمده قابله للتمديد 14 يوما بدا ان بعض
المصادر الاسرائيليه رشحات ان تكون قائمه
الحكومه جاهزه للعرض خلال الاسبوع المقبل
بالتزامن مع اول جلسه للكنيسه المنتخب
بحديث
في اي عوده ستكون لرئيس الوزراء المخضرم
الذي حكم اطول فتره في اسرائيل والمتهم في
قضايا فساد لتامين اغلبيه مستقره من شبه
المؤكد ان يتحالف نتنياهو مع حزب
الصهيونيه الدينيه الذي يتزعمه ايتامار بن
غفير وغيره من احزاب اقصى اليمين يثير اسم
بنفير القلق لدى الفلسطينيين وحتى حلفاء
اسرائيل وعلى راسهم الولايات المتحده من
غفير ترعرع في صفوف حركه كاخ الارهابيه
قبل ان يغادرها لاحقا ويكتفي بلقب اليمني
المتطرف في تاريخه ادانه عام 2007
بالتحريض العنصري ودعم جماعه تعتبرها
واشنطن وتل ابيب ارهابيه تحدث الرئيس سهرت
سوغ عنه خلال مشاوراته مع قاده الاحزاب
التي فازت في الانتخابات الاخيره كان ذلك
في نهايه الاجتماع معتقدا ان الميكروفون
مغلق لكن الصوت وصل الى خارج القاعه
لديكم شريك يشعر العالم باسره حولنا
بالقلق ايذاءه لقد قلت له هذا ايضا هذا
ليس للنشر حقا لا اريد التسبب في مشاكل
[ضحك]
التي اعقبت هذا الكلام لا تعكس المخاوف
الحقيقيه من حكومه تضم بنفير مجرد احتمال
توليه
مشكله كبيره داخليا وخارجيا انجبت سفير
الامريكي في اسرائيل عندما سئل عنه ان
وظيفته كسفير امريكي هي الاستمرار في دفع
الحوار وايضا الاعتراض على الامور التي لا
توافق عليها واشنطن المفارقه المرعبه ان
بنغفر يطالب بوزاره الامن الداخلي
والصنادا للقناه التلفزيونيه الرسميه
يشترط تخصيص موازنات كبيره للوزراء
ويتطلعوا الى تغيير اوامر اطلاق النار
بحيث يمنح عناصر الشرطه حريه اكبر في
اطلاق النار عند الاشتباه في اشخاص ينهون
تنفيذ عمليات
الزواج السياسي المرتقب بين اليمين
واليمين المتطرف في اسرائيل ليس فيه ما
يدعو للاحتفال
الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه والمحاضر في
الجامعه العبريه بالقدس اهلا وسهلا بك
دكتور
الاجواء الان في اسرائيل
تشييك تقريبا بان نتنياهو هو العاقل
الوحيد بين كل هؤلاء المتطرفين وبانه هو
المعتدل هل هذا الانطباع صحيح
اسعد الله مساءكم بالتاكيد نتنياهو يمثل
اليمين وربما الجديد هنا ان اليمين
المتطرف اصبح ايضا شريك له نتنياهو
بالتالي حكومه اليمين واليمين المتطرف بكل
الاحوال نتنياهو يعود مره اخرى الى الحلبه
السياسيه ويشكل الحكومه وقد دعاه رئيس
الدوله رئيس الاسرائيلي الى يوم الاحد
لتسليم التكليف بشكل رسمي ومن ثم يعرض
نتنياهو حكومه ربما يوم الثلاثاء القادم
عندما يبدا الكنيسه في القسم بكل تاكيد
نتنياهو منذ لحظه الاولى التي كانت فيها
نتائج العينات بدا في تشكيله الحكومه
والمشورات مع الفريق الذي يشكل اليمين
واليمين المتطرف ولكن بكل الاحوال هذه
الحكومه سيكون لها تداعيات وهمم تاثير
واثار كبير على الساحه الداخليه
والاقليميه والدوليه صحيفه الاسرائيليه
اشاره اليوم انه اذا اخذ اسمه ريتش همم
وزاره الدفاع واخذ من غفير حقيبه الامن
الداخلي فهذا ستكون له عواقب وخيمه هذا هو
تعبيرعرها اي عواقب
اا يبدو ان اا بالتاكيد صحيفه ارتس اشاره
الى هذا الشيء وابدت مخاوف كبيره وربما
جمهور ايضا جمهور اسرائيلي ربما الذي يمثل
اليسار وجزء ايضا من اليمين الذي ربما
يتبناه نتنياه وهو حزب النقود هناك مخاوف
من تزاعهم او يتراس اسمه حقيبه وزاره
الدفاع واثمار بن جبير لحقيبه وزاره الامن
الداخلي وهذا يعني ان اصبحت المؤسسه
الامنيه والاجهزه الامنيه في يد المتطرفين
وربما ارتمار بن جبير الذي يمثل الحزب
الفاشي همم الكاهاني ومن المعروف ان يتمار
من هو حتى لميد كهانه وترارعها في
ايديولوجيا حركه وربما يوم امس ايضا احتفل
بذكر ايضا وفاته همم
كل هذه الدلالات بالتاكيد تؤكد ان هناك
مخاوف كبيره جدا وسيكون لها دعاياتها على
الساحه الدوليه ولكن المهم هناك اخي محمد
الداخلي الاس اللي هو الان هو المهم
بالنسبه الى نتنياهو ونتنياهو مجبر ان
يمنح اثمار بن قفير وزاره الداخليه ولا
حلول اخرى امام نتنياهو لا خيار اخر امام
نتنياهو لماذا لان نتنياهو يريد ان يتمسك
ويبدا في سن قوانين من اجل اولا ارجاء
محاكمته وابعاد شبح السجن عنتنياهو ومن ثم
سن قوانين جديده هذا المهم بالنسبه له
اشياء داخل الان اهم بكثير من العلاقات
الدوليه او العلاقات الاقليميه ولكن بكل
الاحوال بتقدير ان الملف النووي هو الذي
سيكون مهم بالنسبه للثانيه اما ثمار بن
جرير يتسلم وزاره الامن الداخلي اسمه
مودريتش يتسلم وزاره الدفاع هذا الشيء
داخل الاسرائيلي ونتنياهو بالتاكيد سوف
يحصل على ايضا ربما قوه اكثر من خلال وجود
هذين الشخصين لكي يتمكن من اجنده وسياسيه
يمنيه ايديولوجيه بكل تاكيد نتنياهو سوف
يسعى من خلال هذه الحكومه الى الاستفاده
من سن قوانين في داخل الكنيست والاهم من
ذلك انه سوف يقوم بتجاوز محكمه العدل
العليا وربما يصبح دورها هامشي مقابل سن
القوانين من داخل الكنيست الذي يحظى
باغلبيه 64 كنيسه ولو ادى ذلك الى تسميم
علاقته مع مع واشنطن والاتحاد الاوروبي
نعم بالتاكيد همم اليوم همم يوم امس
الناطق باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه اكد بان
ربما احتفال ومشاركه اثمار بن جبير في همم
ربما همم كهانه وذكر وفاته هذا امر يثير
للشيخ زازا وعمل [__] جدا بالتاكيد سوف
تتاثر علاقات بين امريكا
من الجمهوريين وفي مجلس النواب الامريكي
ولكن هناك ايضا قضيه مهمه همم اخي محمد
وهي ان الجمهور الاسرائيلي لرغم فوزه بهذه
المقاعد 64 من اليمين ولا اليمين المتطرف
ولكن هناك نقطه مهمه على الجمهور
الاسرائيلي والشارع الاسرائيلي يعلم تماما
بان انكار الحقوق المشروع الشعب الفلسطيني
تجاهل وجود الشعب الفلسطيني عدم تبني
نتنياهو لحل الدولتين سوف يؤدي الى
انتفاضه شعبيه عامه وربما ايضا لا بديل
ولا خيار امام الشعب الفلسطيني سوى
ينحى الى خيار اكثر وهو المقاومه المسلحه
التي سوف تاكل الاخضر اليابس من خلال
انتفاضه شعبيه عامه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله شكرا لك الدكتور علي الاعور من
القدس
ونبقى في الملف الفلسطينيه فقد وافقت
اللجنه الرباعيه للجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده المهنيه بانهاء الاستعمار على
مشروع قرار فلسطيني يطلب من محكمه العدل
الدوليه اصدار رائي قانونيا بشان ما اذا
كان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للاراضي
الفلسطينيه يشكل ضمن بحكم الامر الواقع
وسيعرض مشروع القرار على الدول الاعضاء في
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده الشهر
المقبل للتصويت عليه واعتماده بصفه رسميه
ويطلب مشروع القرار من محكمه العدل
الدوليه اصدار راي استشاري يحدد التابعات
القانونيه الناشئه عن انتهاك اسرائيل
للمستمر بحق الشعب الفلسطيني في تقرير
واحتلالها الطويل الامل واستيطانها وضمها
للاراضي واعتمادها تشريعات واجراءات
تميزيه
مرحبا وزير الخارجيه الفلسطينيه رياض
المالكي بتصويت الدول الاعضاء في الامم
المتحده لصالح قرار يطالب فتوى قانونيه من
محكمه العدل الدوليه بشان تصنيف وجود
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للاراضي الفلسطينيه
بما فيها القدس واضاف الملكي ان القرار
تضمن فقرات تعالج الاثار القانونيه
الناجمه عن الخلق الاسرائيلي لحرق الشعب
الفلسطيني في تقرير مصيرهم وتبيعات
القانونيه للفصل العنصريه القائم على
اعتماد تشريعات وتدابير تميزيه اضافه الى
الممارسات والجرائم التي ترتكبها سلطات
الاحتلال وادواتها المختلفه بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني ووصف المالك القرار بانه انتصار
وانجاز دبلوماسي للفلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
حضر الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل الحكومه
من الاستمرار في مواصفات
اللاشعبيه التي تنضرب انفجارات الاجتماعيه
كبيره ناحيه اخرى حضرت حركه الشعب وحراك
35 يوليو المؤيدتان للرئيس سعيد من ان
تؤدي الاوضاع الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه الى
العزوفه عن الانتخابات
الى ضروره الوعي بان مسار الخامس والعشرين
من يوليو كان ضروريه لانقاذ الدوله
تزداد الازمه السياسيه في تونس تعقيدا
يوما بعد يوم انتقادات واسعه تسود الشارع
السياسي مواجهه للرئيس قيس سعيد ومصداغيه
اجراءات الانتخابات التشريعيه المقرر
اجرائها في السابعه عشر من ديسمبر القادمه
يتصدر الحديث عن بسيط الحريات وحقوق
المواطن ووقف اللجوء الى الحلول الامنيه
وفتح حوار المجتمعيه لمجابهه كل اشكال
الجريمه والفوضى وتحقيق ادنى شروط العداله
الاجتماعيه واحتراب القانون مطالبات
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل الذي حذر
حكومه سعيد من الاستمرار فيما وصفها
بالسياسات التي تنظر بانفيارات اجتماعيه
كبيره وبما غبت التفرد بالقراءه في مختلف
الملفات الكبرى في البلاد وقال الاتحاد ان
تمشي الحالي باتجاه انتخابات ديسمبر لا
يسهم في ايجاد الحلول الناجعه
دائمه لحل مشاكل البلاد المتراكمه
ناخذ لم يكن وحيدا في الساحه هذه المره
جاء من مؤيدين للرئيس حركه الشعب حذرت مما
وصفته بتجاوزات خطيره شابت مسار الترشيحات
للانتخابات البرلمانيه المقبله بينها
استعمال المال الفاسد وتدخل المسؤولين
المحليين والجهويين معتبره ان الالتزامات
الحكومه الحاليه مع صندوق النقد الدولي
والتي لم يشارك فيها اي من مسانديها ستؤدي
الى هزات اجتماعيه عنيفه تهدد استقرار
البلاد ومؤسساتها
وكان حراك شباب تونس الوطني المعروف
بحرائق 25 يونيو وهو من المؤيدين ايضا قد
هدد اخيرا بمقاطعه الانتخابات ما لم تصدر
قرارات حازمه تجاه المناخ السياسيه
للانتخابي الراهن الذي يصفه الحرائق
بالملوث والفاسد
حركه النهضه التي تقاطع الانتخابات
المرتقبه وعدد من المنظمات الحقوقيه تتهم
الرئيس بالفشل والديكتاتوريه وبمارسه
تصفيه حسابات سياسيه مع معارضيه بتوظيف
مؤسسات الدوله والقضاء ويقول رئيس الحركه
راشد الغنوشي الذي اطلق سراحه بعد تحقيق
المطول على خلفيه اتهامه بالتامل على امن
الدوله والتقريب الاقتصادي ان الاتهامات
استهدفت الحركه بسبب معارضتها
طب ثبت ان الطريقه للانتخابات السابعه عشر
من ديسمبر محفوف بالجدل والانتقاد في غمره
تخوف واسع من ان يؤدي فشل الحكومه في
التعاطي مع الازمات الاجتماعيه
والسياسيه والاقتصاديه الى هزات اجتماعيه
وشعبيه عنيفه تهدد استقرار البلاد
ومؤسساتها
يعلق الرئيس السعيد في اخر لقاءاته بوزير
الداخليه بالتاكيد على الحرص على تامين
التونسيين في حياتهم ومعاشهم وخاصه التصدي
لظاهره الاحتكار والارتفاع غير المقبول
للاسعار بينما تمضي الحكومه قدما في مسار
انتخابات السابع عشر من يوليو
ينضم الينا من تونس ساموراد اليعقوبي
الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي اهلا وسهلا بك
سيد يعقوب ما اهميه بيان اتحاد الشغل في
ضوء عدم تجاوب السلطات في تونس مع اي
نداءات او بيانات سابقه
[موسيقى]
الشعب او بعض المجموعات الاخرى من الحشد
الموالي لقيس سعيد فكل هذه البيانات
تقريبا
يعني وضعت نفس الكلمات نفس العبارات
كانها صادره عن خيمه يعني عن خيمه واحده
نفس الشيء هي تتكلم في ثقف سياسي واحد لم
تتجاوزه وسقف السياسي هنا هو التوجيه
جميعا النقد للحكومه همم وانا اتسائل هناك
اين يرون هذه الحكومه يعني كل هؤلاء
موظفون لدى قيس سعيد وبالتالي الذي يركض
الحكومه دون النظر الى ما فوقها والى انها
تطبق سياسات قيس سعيد في نهايه الامر وحتى
صفحه الرئاسه شهد على ذلك في كل لقاء يوجه
قيس سعيد همم موظفوه من ما يعتبرهم وزاراء
ويواجهم توجه توجهات معينه ينفذون تلك
التوجهات ولم نسمع لاحد منهم رايا او
قرارا او موقفا او رؤيه في الاصلاح او
توجه معينه وبالتالي يعني هذه كل هذه
العلامات تدل ان حتى ال ال ال الذين
يبدونك معارضين فانهم في الحقيقه
يساندون قصائد بشكل اخر لانهم ما زالوا
يتحدثون عن لحظه 25 مجويليه وكانها لحظه
وعي او ربما لحظه نبوه اكثر من ذلك همم
هذا فيه دليل على انه ما زال يقفون تحت
سقف مسيناتنا الانقلاب وبالتالي هم الان
ببياناتهم هذه يوجهون نصائح لقاء سعيد ولا
يعبرون عن موقف لما حدث من 25 جنيه وعن
وعي حقيقي بالازمه العميقه التي تسير فيها
البلاد وربما يمكن حتى
الان ايضا من تونس عبر الهاتف بالاحسن
الاحياء والكاتب والمحلل السياسي
نساله عن مدى قدره ال ال الحكومه والرئيس
قيس سعيد بالدرجه الاولى على التجاوب مع
بعض هذه النداءات والبيانات وبعضها من من
انصاره
سعيد فهو يبدو في اغلب الاحيان يصم اذنيه
عن كل تلك الدعوات التي تاتي سواء كانت من
مؤيديه او من مناوي
[موسيقى]
يعني عن طريق هذا المخطط احيانا تكون هذه
الاستجابه استجابه الى ما يرده تونسي
وان كانت في المعارضه او كانت في الموالات
تاتي بصوره متاخره نسبيه ولكن في مقابل
ذلك تحاول الحكومه الحاليه
مع مختلف الحساسيات يعني السياسيه او
الجمعيه او حتى يعني من هم المواطنين
اثناء عملها ولكن المساله الاساسيه المهمه
الان هو انه ليس هناك واجهه لطلاصل وان
بين الحكومه وبين مختلف فئات الشعب
التونسي او بين الرايس قيس سعيد وبين
مختلف فئات الشعب التونسي خاصه ونحن نقل
او ان العد التنازلي نحو انهاء حاله
الاستثناء قد اقترب في حاله الاستثمار
تنتهي نظريا بالانتخابات التشريعيه
السابقه لاوانها
الاحيانا يبدو كان الامور تكاد الطفله من
بين يديه سواء رئيس الجمهوريه الصعيد او
حكومه مجلس كما ان الانسجام بصراحه يبدو
خائبا بين الطرفين تذهب الحكومه الى اتفاق
مع صندوق النقد الدولي محصلات هذه الاتفاق
سوف تؤدي الى ارتفاع كلفه الحياه في تونس
لا يزال يسر الرئيس سعيد بخطاباته او
بتوجيهاته على انه لا تقليد في المؤسسات
العموميه ليس هناك رخصه للدعم ليس هناك
ضغط او ليس هناك امكانيه لكي يتحمل الشعب
لو مختلف فئات الشعب التونسي الكلفه
الحياتيه التي سوف تنتج عن الاتفاق مع
صندوق النقد الدولي لهذا الاتفاق تحديدا
السيد بالاحسن وهنا نسال السيد مراد
اليعقوبي همم واضح ان هذا الاتفاق اخذ
حيزا هاما من بيان اتحاد الشغل اعتبر ان
الحكومه
تفاوضت واتفقت مع صندوق النقد الدولي بشكل
احادي لم تشرك احد وحدرتها من ما غبت
المضيق قدما في ذلك هل هل يمكن ان تتجاوب
الحكومه مع طلبات كهذه
قبل ان يجيب على ذلك اود ان اسال الاتحاد
نفسه والتبوبي الذي حضر مع الحكومه ومع
نقابه الاعراف وانظر اساله على ماذا امضيت
يا صديقي هل يمكن ان تمضي على اتفاق هدنا
اجتماعيه دون ان تعرف ما تقدم عليه البلاد
جميع كان يتحدث عن قروض وعن تنازلات وما
الى ذلك هذا ليس اكثر من تلهي واكثر من
استبليه للناس فالاتحاد كان يعرف هذا
الاتجاه وهذا المسار ولكنه كان قابلا بذلك
واليوم يتراجع ولا اراه لذلك لا اراه في
هذه التصريحات اكثر من فرقعات اعلاميه هي
فقط من باب رفع الملامه وخاصه ان النقد
يتوجه اساسا الى الحكومه وليس الى الذي
يتراس الحكومه الذي يمسك بكل السلط وهؤلاء
اذكر قوله لاحد الصالحين في الزمان السابق
قال من خطب عن الزنا في مدينه همم في شيء
فيها فقد خان الامام الامانه اذا الذي سار
في هذا المسار وما زال يتحدث عن لحظه 25
وما زال يتامل ان يقع التدفق به وما الى
ذلك محاولات التقرب ضمن منه ان الرئيس قيس
سعيد يعني يمكن ان تنط لي عليه هذه
الخطابات والجميله
مع ذلك الرئيس سعيد وانهي بالسيد بالحسن
اليحيوي باختصار رجاءا الرئيس سعيد يتحدث
مره اخرى عن العوده الى الشعب والاحتكام
الى الشعب في اشاره منه للانتخابات
المقبله في اجواء كهذه انتخابات 17 ديسمبر
ما قيمتها
الان في الحقيقه لا يمكن ان نحكم مسبقا
على قيمه هذه الانتخابات نحن مضطرون
للانتظار للنظر الى موقعين الاساسيه
هو النسبه المشاركه في هذه الانتخابات هل
تصل اعداد المشاركه الى تلك الممثلات التي
شاركت في الاستفتاء او التي شاركت في
المناسبات الانتخابيه السابقه ثم بعد ذلك
نتيجه هذه الانتخابات او المشهد او
العناصر المكونه للبرلمان المقبل الان
طبعا يبدو ان هذا هو الامتحان الاخير
للرئيس سعيد وان نجاح هذه الانتخابات
والوصول الى نسبه مشاركه مقبوله على الاقل
في هذه الانتخابات سوف
انهيار كل المسار الذي اعلن عليه الرئيس
الامر يبدو مقبولا شكرا جزيلا همم
بالاحسان اليحياوي ومراد اليعقوب من تونس
في موضوع اخر وبعد اعلان شركه بن انس التي
تعد احد اكبر مواقع تداول العملات الرقميه
في العالم تخليها عن صفقه شراء منصه اف تي
اكس للعملات المشفره اعلنت منصه العملات
الرقميه اف تي اكس الكبيره افلاسها كما
استقال رئيسها علما انها احد اكبر بورصات
العملات المشفره في العالم وياتي ذلك بعد
فشلها في الحصول على تمويل جديد واثرا
دفاع العملاء للانسحاب منها
ضربه كبرى جديده اطاحت باسعار العملات
الرقميه التي شهدت تراجعات قياسيه في
اسعارها منذ بدايه العام الجاري
هذه الضربه تمثلت في اعلان شركه باينس
التي تعد احد اكبر مواقع تداول العملات
الرقميه في العالم تخليها عن صفقتها
الكبيره المتمثله في شراء منصه اف تي اكس
للعملات المشفره واوضحت بينس انها ستتخلى
عن شراء تلك البورصه الرقميه نتيجه لمخاوف
تتعلق بممارساتها التجاريه وبسبب
التحقيقات التي تجريها الولايات المتحده
بشان اداء هذه المنصه اضافه الى معانات
هذه البورصه من ازمه سيوله قياسيه
وكشفت صحيفه فينشل تايمز البريطانيه ان
منصه اف تي اكس صارت في حاجه ماسه الى
ثمانيه مليارات دولار وذلك لتعرضها
لعمليات سحب اموال قياسيه من عملائها اكثر
من ذلك اعلنت لجنه الاوراق الماليه
والبورصات الامريكيه توسيع نطاق تحقيق
القانوني مع هذه منصه ويتضمن هذا التحقيق
قضايا اقراض العمله فراغ وسوء اداره اموال
العلماء هذه الازمه تسببت في خساره القيمه
السوقيه للعملات المشفره اكثر من 200
مليار دولار خلال اقل من 30 ساعه هذا
الامر يعني تهاوي قيمه هذه العملات الى
808 مليارات دولار وذلك من مستوى من بلغ
تريليون و65 مليار دولار قبل هذه الازمه
اكثر من ذلك خسرت عمله بيتكوين خلال 24
ساعه فقط اكثر من 12% من قيمتها كما خسرت
تلك العمله المشفره 20% من قيمتها خلال
سبعه ايام كما نقلت وكاله بلومبرج عن
مصادر مطلعه قولها ان مؤسس منصه اف تي اكس
سامبا قد يتقدم بطلب لاعلان افلاسه اذا لم
تحصل منصه على تمويل
وبحسب مؤشر بلومبرج للملياردورات انخفض
صافي ثروه فرايد من 15 مليارا و600 مليون
دولار يوم الاثنين الماضي الى 901 مليون
ونصف المليون دولار ياتي ذلك في الوقت
الذي وسعت فيه العملات المشفره خسائرها
لتفقد نحو 100 90 مليار دولار من قيمتها
السوقيه على مدى اسبوع كما تجاوزت خسائر
تلك العملات الرقميه منذ بدايه العام
الجاري اكثر من تريليون دولار
[موسيقى]
حضر الاتحاد الاوروبي من ان منطقه اليورو
ستدخل في حاله ركود خلال الشتاء بينما
رفعت بروكسيل توقعتها بشان معدلات التضخم
للعامين 2022 و 2023 على خلفيه ارتفاع
اسعار الطاقه وافاده المفوضيه الاوروبيه
بان زياده ضبابيه الوضع وارتفاع التكاليف
يتوقع ان يدخل منطقه اليورو ومعظمه بلدان
التكتل في حاله ركود في الفصل الاخير من
هذا العام
هذا الخبر سيكون له الكثير من التدعيات
هذه هي منطقه اليوم التي تحدثت عنها
المفوضيه الاوروبيه تسعه عشره دوله كما
تشاهدون كلها كلها بحسب المفوضيه ستواجه
انكماشا في اقتصاداتها لكن ما هو الانكماش
يحدث عندما تنخفض اسعار السلع بمعنى ان
القيمه الشرائيه للعمله تصبح اكبر يبدو
الامر جيدا في البدايه لكنه ليس كذلك ويعد
اسوء واخطر من التضخم حيث ان هذا الانخفاض
باسعار السلع يترافقوا مع عدم رغبه
المستهلكين بالشراء فيتراجع الاستهلاك
سريعا تنخفض الجدوى بالنسبه للمستثمرين
والمنتجين فتتراجع اعمالهم ويبداون
بالتخلص من الموظفين فتزدادوا نسبه
البطاله
لا يتوقف الامر عند هذا الحد بل سرعان ما
تنخفض ايضا قيمه الاصول الماليه وتنخفض
كذلك ايرادات الدوله من الضرائب هذا حديث
اقتصادي صرف بطبيعه الحال لكن بالنسبه
للقاره الاوروبيه فهو امر اشكالي ومتشعب
على اكثر من صعيد المفوضيه الاوروبيه
افادت بان الوضع ازداد ضبابيه مع ارتفاع
التكاليف بسبب حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
فبات الناس اكثر حذرا واقل رغبه في
الاقبال على الشراء
وتوقعت ان يسجل معدل التضخم ثمانيه فاصل
خمسه بالمئه هذا العام اي اعلى بنقطه من
التوقعات السابقه وقد واجهت الكتله اسعار
اعلى لاسيما اسعار الطاقه والغذاء خلال
الاشهر 12 المقبله حيث ارتفعت تكاليف
تكاليف الطاقه بنسبه تقارب
42% بين ما زادت
اسعار المواد الغذائيه بالنسبه تجاوزت
ال13% ينضم الينا الان من برلين الدكتور
توماس
اودونال الخبير في شؤون الاقتصاد والطاقه
والاستاذ بمدرسه
العليا ببرلين اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور ما
الذي ننتظره من هذا الانكماش بشكل خاص
مساء الخير شكرا على الاستضافه مره اخرى
معكم اذا ما نظرنا الى
المفوض
جنتلوني وما قاله اليوم المفوض الخاصه
بشؤون الطاقه لم يكن التقرير ايجابيا وانا
اعتقد انه محيط ان التضخم ما يزال عاليا
في الاتحاد الاوروبي وهم قاموا به مراجعه
التخمينات المركز المصرف المركزي ايضا قام
بزياده سعر الصرف همم
بثلاثه مرات الان السؤال هو هل يجب ان يجب
ان يسيطر على تضخم جانب مهم هو الطاقه
ونعرف جيدا ان هناك ازمه طاقه يستفيد من
هذا الامر هو ادائه عسكري سيء جدا في
اوكراني بالتالي وهو يعتمد على حرب الطاقه
ويزيد من سوء الوضع الاقتصادي في اوروبا
بالتالي هنالك عاصفه مثاليه تواجه اوروبا
الان وسيكون الصعب الموقف صعبا للغايه
واعتقد ان هذا ما فهمناه من تصريحات السيد
جنتلوني اليوم
الا تبدو دول اوروبا
نوعا ما هشه بسبب حرب لم تصل حتى للعام
وكل هذه الاثار المختلفه على الاقتصاد
الجوانب الايجابيه وجوانب اخرى السلبيه
الجوانب السلبيه هي ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
كان غير مهيا لهذه الحرب بالتاكيد عسكريه
انهم لم يكن مهيائين بشكل كافي لم يتوقعوا
من نقود ان يقوم ذلك على الرغم من ان
الدول في شرق اوروبا توقعت ذلك الولايات
المتحده لكن المانيا وفرنسا والدول الاخرى
الكبرى في اوروبا لم تتوقع ذلك
كانوا يعتمدونها في مجال الطاقه وخاصه
المانيا كانوا يعتمدون بشكل كبير واصر على
الاعتماد بشكل كبير على الغاز الروسي
وفي وقت الذي كانت فيه الدول الغربيه
والدول الشمال اشاره الى ان كان هذا الامر
خطا كبيرا بالتالي هذه هشاشه وهذا الضعف
والاعتبار الزائد على الطاقه في بعض
الاحيان على الريح وهذا الامر ليس فعالا
اعتقد ان همم كان همم قوه ايضا قد اصيب
بالصدمه لمستوى الموقف الموحد لم يتحدث
كان هنالك استمرار بالحديث مثلا عن فرض
عقوبات على روسيا
وكان هنالك مثلا ايقاف كل البترول والغاز
الذي ياتي على عبر البحر كان هذا امرا
مهما اذا لدينا ازمه اقتصاديه وهنالك
ولدينا موقف موحد لكنها لم تجعل هذه
الازمه لم تجبر القاده على التراجع
بالتالي كما قلت هنالك جوانب سلبيه وجوانب
اخرى ايجابيه
شكرا جزيلا دكتور توماس اودونال الخبير في
شؤون الاقتصاد والطاقه والاستاذ بمدرسه
العليا في برلين
[موسيقى]
قبل ان ننهي الحصاد الليله نتوقف عند
تحذير قد لا يبدو جديدا على مسامعنا في كل
عام تحذر المنظمات الدوليه من قساوه
الشتاء على الابواب غزواته على من لامولهم
من النازحين واللاجئين الامم المتحده وجهت
نداء لتقديم التبرعات للملايين من هؤلاء
النازحين والناجحين في انحاء العالم
ومساعدتهم على تخطي الشتاء الخارج
الملايين من هؤلاء قريبون منه مثلا في
لبنان يعيشوا تسعه من كل عشره لاجئين تسعه
من كل عشره لاجئين سوريين فكرا
لنجعل لهؤلاء نصيبا من عونه تصبحون على
خير
[موسيقى]